hey I don't want to spend a lot of time
on this but I do want to ask you whether
you want this to do a 20-19 david pakman
show calendar we're in the middle of
moving studios there's a lot of stuff
going on very hectic but that's also a
great reason to do the calendar thing
since it could help to raise some money
so as a reminder we did a hatred mail
themed calendar in 2015 we did a hatred
mail themed calendar in 2016 I'm holding
these up for the audience we did a what
would you call the 2017 calendar Iverson
coloring a cartoon coloring book themed
calendar for 2017 and then we did the
2018 calendar was also a a cartoon style
calendar so if we are going to do it for
2019 number one we've got to get going
on the design pretty soon because we
want usually we want to have it go on
sale either like the last few days of
October but definitely like the bulk of
November in December we like to have the
calendar on sale we usually offer it for
free with new yearly memberships or just
by the standalone calendar with the
discount for existing members the other
thing is I I know that a lot of people
will say oh that seems really cool but
with peace and love we need to know
whether you would buy one right because
if we're gonna go through the work I
mean I'm not looking for firm
commitments or down payments but email
me david at david pakman.com if you
would purchase one of these right
because unless we're going to sell at
least several hundred of them it's not
really worth doing it but every year I
often think to myself we're probably not
going to do it this year
and then around this time as has
happened people start emailing and they
say David what's up with the 2019
calendar I've got art I want to
contribute or I want to help with this
or that so let me know I guess I'm up
for doing it I'm ready to do the work to
get this thing done if people actually
want to buy them personally I'd like to
see this streak continue right we've
been doing this for four years so I'd
like to see a fifth year it's just funny
in a sense though because the summer
just ended and we're already talking
about 29 cat 2019 calendars but you know
this is just how it has to be yes I'm
just saying this is this is production
Pat it's time to put on your big-boy
pants and let's buckle down and get the
calendar done that's all it is and if
people say it's time to do it then Pat
is going to
tell me that I need to do it obviously
gotta start making some pictures
yeah I'm can see my illustrative talents
do you have things to submit Oh No okay
I mean I may have an in here I may be
able to get like the month of March I
could possibly get August but I'm not
getting January or February
no definitely not August of course big
vacation months so that would be where
we would relegate like the worst art or
something like that but anyway let me
know david at david pakman.com